Speaker 1: A book banning Republican is very
quickly learning about the potentially unintended
consequences of his own actions as a parent is now
using the law to try to get the Bible banned. And
I have to tell you, it makes a lot of sense.
LGBTQ Nation Rt.com Reports Book Ban Lawmaker
Quote Very sad. I don't know why I find very sad
to be funny that a parent is using his law to ban
the sex written Bible. The parent said that if
lesser books have been banned, then the Bible,
which discusses infanticide, rape and bestiality,
is not appropriate for kids. I mean that it makes
a lot of sense. A Utah parent reads The article
has challenged the Bible under a state law banning
pornographic or indecent materials in schools.
It has been used to remove books by mostly LGBTQ,
plus and black authors from shelves in a book
challenge submitted to Davis School District.
The unnamed parent called the Bible, quote,
one of the most sex written books around,
according to the Salt Lake Tribune. Utah State
Representative Ken Ivory, who sponsored HB 374,
described the request as a political stunt that
would rein drained school resources. There was a
purpose to the bill and this kind of stuff. It's
very unfortunate. Now, of course, that's true. The
purpose of the bill was not to actually ban all
of this type of content. It was only to ban the
content that this guy doesn't like. And that
is fundamentally what this is all about. And
if we are to say, let's apply their standards,
the Bible must be bad. That's the reality. Now,
I'm not out there advocating for anything to
be banned, but if these are the standards,
graphic descriptions of sexual activity. One
example is, of course, Song of Solomon seven
one through nine, where a woman describes her
lover's body in sensual detail. It's basically
a romance novel. Several stories in the Bible are
just filled with explicit sexual content rape,
incest, Genesis 19 Angels save Lott and his family
from the destruction of Sodom and Gomorrah. Lott
offers his Virgin daughters to the men to be raped
in exchange for their safety. Edgy doesn't really
quite cover that storyline, I must say. Ezekiel
2320 Graphic Description of two Sisters engaging
in Sexual Activity with Multiple Partners. Genesis
38 The Story of Judas Son Put to Death by God for
Wickedness. And right before he dies, he engages
in sexual activity with his daughter in law,
who is disguised as a sex worker. Folks, if this
is actually the standard, the content, and not
whether it's Christian content or black content
or whatever, then the Bible must be banned.
Of course, that is not the point of these
bills. I'm sure you understand. But they
want there to be a special status for
the Bible. And I believe that if we
have these standards, they should apply
to all reading materials, Bible included.